- [Narrator] This might look
like your typical Western background,
but it's actually an abandoned set…
Of a video game.
- The Western was easy to
accomplish here in New Mexico.
We have the sets, we have the
cowboys, we have the horses.
We had everything we needed.
- [Narrator] Including a great villain.
Mad Dog McCree.
(evil laughter)
- There had never been a
live-action interactive
video arcade game, until
Mad Dog came along.
(video game music)
- [Narrator] The year was 1990,
the dawn of a new age of videos
games was about to begin.
Arcades had small but powerful
rivals in the living room.
The smallest, the Game Boy.
Born in 1989.
The scariest, the home
console, SEGA 16-bit Genesis
and Nintendo's Super NES.
Now, anyone can play high-end video games,
anywhere they wanted.
Arcade makers had to step up
and utilize their main advantage.
More storage space that could
hold hours of video footage.
Instead of computer generated graphics,
they used live-action, live
dialogue, and live actors.
The type of production values
that console games couldn't touch.
Which brings us back to where we started,
New Mexico, a place where
a one of a kind experiment
changed the video game industry, forever.
The props from that first live-
action game, still remain,
in a dusty warehouse, outside Albuquerque.
(coughing)
- I'm Dave Roberts, and I was
director on Mad Dog McCree.
Hands up.
It was our first entry into video games.
- These are the fake dynamite sticks.
- [Narrator] The makers of
Mad Dog weren't always in the
business of making video games.
They actually got their
start making police training
simulators.
- We shot things that police
would encounter during
their day,
they put it up on a big screen,
and the police officer
would walk into room,
he would have a pistol that
had a laser put into it,
and he would respond to
whatever was happening
on the screen.
Once we knew how to do that,
it made it a little easier
to do Mad Dog McCree.
- My name is Robert Grebe,
and I was the CEO of
American Laser Games.
This is the aha moment, actually.
Looking at this picture, I
realized that there was a
potential to turn this
simulator into a video game.
So,
that became Mad Dog, Mad Dog McCree.
- [Narrator] The team now
had the technology to make a
video game.
But what they needed was a story.
Being located in New Mexico,
the Wild West was an obvious choice.
And they didn't have to go too far
to find their stars.
(western music)
- My name is Russ Dillen,
and I played Mad Dog McCree.
I’ve lived in New Mexico all my life,
I was born and raised here on this ranch.
I've been out here for 60 years.
We started shooting Mad Dog,
nobody knew who Mad Dog was,
or who it was gonna be.
Bob Grebe decided I would
make a good Mad Dog.
Obviously not for my looks.
Probably was ’cause I could quick draw.
I was pretty quick in those days.
- [Narrator] Finding a Mad
Dog who could quick draw,
was easy.
But transforming a blond-
haired, blue-eyed rancher,
into a rough and tumble
outlaw form the Wild West,
that's a different story.
- I guess the most time
consuming part was the makeup
and the hair stuff.
And that hair dye's a mess.
If I'd sweat, you know,
and do this, it'd be
black stuff rolling down
my forehead.
- When I saw him at
first dressed as Mad Dog,
I had no clue it was my husband.
It was kind of like
looking at somebody else.
- I feel like it's sticking
really well, isn't it?
I was dressed in everything black,
and that horrid orange scarf,
looks almost like a carnival thing, but
I guess that became the
trademark of Mad Dog,
was that orange scarf.
- [Narrator] The plot of
Mad Dog McCree goes something
like this:
a gang of outlaws has laid
claim to a small town.
Kidnapping the mayor, and his daughter.
The player's job is to kill
the member's of the gang,
and eventually, Mad Dog himself,
freeing the town from terror.
(screaming woman)
Because players competed
against live actors in the game,
the biggest challenge was
accounting for unpredictability.
The crew had to shoot each scene in a way
that allowed for multiple outcomes,
of the same situation.
- We've got four people in the shot.
Who does the player shoot first?
Oh my, he shoots number one first.
But, what if he shot number four first?
Well, we've gotta film that, too.
- In one scene alone, I'm
probably four different people.
I'm one of the guy that
jumps into the street
and tries to shoot you,
and then as you're walking
up the street, to the saloon,
me and Al come out fighting.
- [Director] And action.
(grunting)
- And stay down.
And stay out.
- It was pretty corny, you know.
But yeah, there's always, you know, a
special place for Mad Dog,
'cause of what it was and what it became.
- We didn't know if the
game would be a success.
We didn't know if the
product would work or not.
I mean, it was on the job
training for all of us.
♪ It's hard to see the light ♪
♪ Shining so bright. ♪
- It really exploded instantly
in popularity worldwide,
'cause nobody had ever
seen anything like it.
♪ You've had a long, long run. ♪
- You could hardly get near a game,
'cause it was just so popular.
♪ Through the rain ♪
♪ Through the heat ♪
♪ You won't always sleep alone ♪
♪ But you won’t ever stay the week ♪
♪ You better run ♪
- I really appreciate just how much
that we accomplished back 20 years ago.
- I never really thought that
Mad Dog would have a legacy.
But it's iconic in that it really sort of
represented this moment of time when
video gaming went from Pong and Pac-Man,
to Grand Theft Auto, you know.
I think it was a wonderful
stepping stone for the industry.